voyez vous avez trois haut parleurs
celui là a vraiment centralisé un petit
peu le son tandis que les deux autres
pour parler de spatialiser un petit peu
plus et là vous avez le caisson de
basses qui envoie du
[Musique]
e
mesdames mesdemoiselles et messieurs je
fais tenir la caméra pourquoi qu'elle
tombe c'est à dire j'ai déjà fait tomber
le jour la caméra sa map est l objectif
si ça peut ne pas tomber
ça n'arrange bon salut bienvenue à la
maison
je vous emmène aujourd'hui dans la
tanière dans mon antre pour parler de
son jeu parle de son parce que sony
m'envoyer un truc assez cool
il s'agit de ça on a une barre de son
htz f9 dolby atmos des tsx verticale
enfin il ya plein de trucs et on amène
mis un joli petit mot ici ne pas écraser
doudou première chose à faire bien
s'équiper pour ouvrir le carton
[Musique]
on a quoi derrière de hdmi in on a une
entrée lan on a hdmi sortie on à de
l'usb tv in obstine hockey bongo qui
sont graves son fils grave puissante
christianisme cher adrien heureuse de te
faire parvenir notre dernière barre de
son haut de gamme
le z f9 faisant bon usage à bientôt
morgan
merci morgan
[Musique]
bon verdict alors c'est toujours
compliqué de pareilles d'audio parce que
bon coup c'est un truc vous vous
percevez pas directement et moi c'est un
truc que je perçois alors j'ai décidé de
vous expliquer un peu ce que nous
apporte cette barre de son plus son
caisson de basses vous vous en douterez
on peut écouter de la musique le son est
cool
il ya des basses serré abl ça c'est la
base
et ça franchement c'est assez
intéressant et ça marche plutôt bien
mais bien évidemment ça ce n'est que la
partie émergée de l'iceberg
parce que avec cette barre de son vous
pouvez faire beaucoup plus de choses
d'ailleurs est de faire une mise à jour
donc vous avez bien évidemment google
assistant dessus vous avez amazon avec
ça ça c'est pas mal
vous avez spotify pour écouter de la
musique ça c'est aussi franchement hyper
cool donc votre barre de son qui certes
a profité je dirais d'un visionnage de
films de qualité blu ray de quatre
cadavres vraiment un son immersif du
coup vous pouvez aussi utiliser pour
écouter de la musique chez vous et en
tant qu assistant personnel donc ça
c'est aussi très intéressant
alors on va partir par la base
connectique déjà hyper facile à brancher
moi je les branches sont à box votre box
directement à l'enceinte en hdmi et
ensuite en hdmi de l'enceinte jusqu'à
votre télé c'est simple ça mange bien le
caisson de basses celui se branche
directement en bluetooth même pas besoin
de synchroniser il était reconnu
directement
franchement c'est hyper hyper hyper
facile vous n'avez pas particulièrement
bon on a récupéré un petit garçon avec
moi qui est juste là travail at ouest
moi j'ai ma box qui reliait directement
ici elle elle est reliée directement en
bluetooth ou caisson de basses est
ensuite l'enceinte qui hélas est relié
directement à la télé alors ça une télé
un peu old school m'en voulez pas alors
voilà comment s'articulent vous avez
plusieurs parties vous avez une partie
regarder la télé donc là typiquement hop
je me mets la hd amiens là bon je vous
passe le truc c'est de la télé ces
standards vous avez ensuite la partie
écoutez là vous allez pouvoir brancher
vos device en bluetooth donc vous allez
pouvoir m ça va vous allez pouvoir avoir
maître du bluetooth de la musique
bluetooth de l'audio bluetooth depuis
votre smartphone ou votre tablette ce
que voulait branché en usb branché
directement un câble net spotify
du coup votre barre de son vous servira
d'enceinte connectés et en plus
connectés bien sûr parce que vous avez
amazon avec ça et bien évidemment google
assistants et vous avez ensuite le crom
caste et c'est justement là où c'est
intéressant ça votre barre de son jeu
prend par exemple la légère l'ipad caché
dans cette espèce de truc je peux
envoyer directement mon contenu youtube
netflix par exemple canal+ mais film
tout ce qui est compatible chrome caste
je prends les gens voient directement là
alors votre barbe fond vous devez elle a
connecté à internet vous pouvez faire
soit directement avec un câble ethernet
soit la branche et en wifi sur votre
réseau et tous les device qui seront
connectés sur ce réseau là pourront
comcast et et ça franchement c'est hyper
intéressant petit exemple si par exemple
vous avez un abonnement canal+ mais vous
l'avez pas sur votre télé vous avez
quand même pouvoir regarder des trucs
avec votre abonnement canal+ qui va
coûter moins cher que si vous avez un
abonnement directement sans votre télé
et ça c'est aussi très intéressant
donc en réalité cette barre de son n'est
pas juste une barre de son que vous
permet d'avoir du son de qualité et de
profiter une sensation beaucoup plus
immersive dans votre intérieur
c'est beaucoup plus que ça cette barre
de son devient un petit peu votre
appareil centrale pour tous qui va être
multimédia audio vidéo blu ray et
compagnie la qualité audio parlons-en
justement et c'est ça qui est aussi très
intéressant c'est que vous avez
plusieurs modes vous allez pouvoir
choisir
cinéma musique gueye non je n'ose c'est
de l'irlande à se compliquer le sport
standard dont vous avez plusieurs prêts
cet audio ça vous permet donc de
calibrer complètement l'audio par
rapport au type de contenu que vous
allez visionner c'est vraiment hyper
optimisé autre temps qui est super
content c'est le fait d'avoir ce qu'ils
appellent un sont verticales
alors je sais c'est hyper compliqué à
définir sur une vidéo comme ça vous avez
dû sont verticales
alors on est dire on a dû sourire en
talent du saut vertical en fait l'idée
ça va rendre le sont beaucoup plus
englobant il faut imaginer que vous êtes
assis votre télé en face votre barre de
son est votre question de base doivent
voter ou de l'autre pourquoi pas au
milieu vous est proposé dans ce monde
beaucoup plus immersif comme si vous
aviez en rond à cinq points alors c'est
pas 1,5 point vous avez votre trois
points de vente
plus votre enceinte vous avez votre
trois points en face de vous mais
néanmoins c'est beaucoup plus englobant
et ça c'est franchement hyper
intéressant donc si on récapitule
on a une enceinte connectés qui est plus
qu'une enceinte connectés qui est le
coeur de votre vie multimédia
directement chez vous sur lequel vous
allez profiter de votre télé vous avoir
protesté m spotify amazon avec ça google
assistant vous allez pouvoir envoyer de
l'audio en bluetooth allait pouvoir
faire vachement de choses
tout ça se connecte directement sur
internet et vous branchez votre caisson
de basses directement en bout tous ces
merveilleux
en plus de ça c'est complètement tactile
j'allume j'éteins s'est complètement
intégré ce qui fait que ça se voit pas
du tout c'est franchement hyper bien
fait l'enceinte en elle même est
vraiment bien réussi ça c'est aimanté
samedi rappelle se positionner devant
ils voyaient vous avez trois haut
parleurs celui là a vraiment centralisé
un petit peu le son tandis que les deux
autres pour permettre de spatialiser un
petit peu plus et là vous avez le
caisson de basses qui envoie du steak et
qui marche super bien et en plus vous
avez un petit écran qui intégrait ça
rajoute un effet qui est vachement sympa
c'est très esthétique
baissez vous faire écouter un petit peu
ce que ça donne niveaux sont alors c'est
un peu compliqué parce que la
restitution va pas être parfaite
j'ai juste un micro qui est positionné
au dessus de la caméra ça va pas être
top mais pour essayer se rencontrent un
petit peu du son
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est hyper compliqué de rendre ça sur
une vidéo youtube parce que ça dépend
sur quoi vous l'écoutez si vous êtes
dans les transports en commun si vous
êtes au casque si vous l'écoutez sur un
smartphone destiné aux côtés sur un
ordinateur vous aurez pas du tout le
même rendu mais croyez-moi le dos je
trouve vraiment intéressant je trouve
qu'il ya une vraie spatialisation ça
c'est la base c'est la base vous achetez
une enceinte une enceinte connectez vous
voulez d'abord qui est un bosseur un
beau sont restitués et je trouve que là
dessus sony à faire vrai beau boulot et
il arrive en plus à repositionner le
produit parce que une barre de son plus
un caisson de basses c'est vraiment bien
connu et avec un produit comme celui là
il arrive vraiment à repositionner le
produit sur le marché pour le rendre
beaucoup plus intelligent beaucoup plus
connectés et j'ai alors là moi j'ai une
télé qui date de l'an 40 vous faites ça
avec un écran bravia oled avec derrière
un lecteur blu ray avec quelque chose
qui va être juste hyper optimiser
l'expérience d'être absolument
complètement dingue
et ça c'est juste génial alors vous en
douterez c'est pas un produit qui va
être hyper hyper cadeaux l'ensemble
coûte 799 euros
mais si vous voulez vous équiper pour
avoir quelque chose qui est quand même
assez compact qui est très beau qui
fonctionne parfaitement bien avec une
excellente qualité sonore et qui est
complètement connecté
la sony htz f9 pourra franchement vous
séduire dites moi ce que vous en pensez
en voix en commentaire est ce que vous
l'avez déjà cette enceinte connectée est
ce que vous en avez une similaire est-ce
qu'elle pourrait vous intéresser
on parlera d'audio dites moi si c'est un
sujet qui vous intéresse sur lequel vous
avez des attentes si vous avez des
questions par rapport à tout ça et je
vous donne rendez vous très bientôt
d'ici là soyez sages et prenez soin de
vous